hello there the Internet I'm Gavin I'm
done weird the slow mo guys and we're
filming something that I've never seen
in slow-motion before I'm not sure how
many people have in submissions what
we've got here is a number 11 grade 60
rebar so it's pure steel beam basically
it's one and a half inches thick so it's
absolute beast and uh we're gonna pull
it apart yeah we could have ripped it
apart using this here machine now I've
been working my back recently yeah well
first let's see if you can pull it apart
Oh God
you want to tug O'War let's try it let's
sew this apparently is like it has rated
to how much it can be pulled apart and
this one can pull apart up to 220 Kip's
which is 220,000 pounds of pulling apart
force and we want to find out what this
will break it what's that horsepower
tariff code of one fleet let's split oh
goodness sake
ready ready it has begun
world's meatiest machine is doing its
work the hard part will be is like
guessing the framing so I've come quite
wide but seeing everything from probably
got like 12 12 old ones they're on sixty
Kip's 60,000 it's going to make noise
now yeah
you get the occasional creak yeah it's
gonna be loud I wonder field what we'll
see some physical stretching 79 80 80
Kip's
oh it's falling off there yeah I got
more hits than friends oh I'm really
nervous
oh yeah 100 500 like that oh it's like
the inside is stretching more than the
outside oh I'm scared 125
Oh God I don't think we're gonna have
the frame rate for this
oh she's hit whatever what are we at we
didn't fully punch boy that was it oh
that's like 10 mega stone mega stone
just go any day now oh go on son
Oh God look let's watch oh okay
stretching oh oh good lord lovely clean
break one hundred and fifty seven point
four thousand pounds
come on all right let's see what I've
bet oh it gets dark like a cloud of mist
that's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the best way to clean a steel bar
is to break it in half that means no
governor's left I do that but they know
this stuff from above came down later
yeah sure when oh absolutely did look at
this this is actually amazing because
this fits the the bit actually broke
it's really warm to the touch so let you
start hearing it's cold and it just gets
warmer and warmer and it's just like hot
cuz it's stretched out of my so much
guys yeah that's just from the friction
that's you from the stretch in it cause
the heat is really cool bloody how so to
set the Machine up before you can start
pulling it has to like grip in an either
end and you can see here where the grips
have just cut into the steel
hey like just absolutely completely
crushes it so that you can pull it apart
and you can see the little individual
notches that was hefty how scary
I jumped it's amazing how it just cleans
it takes out the entire layer itself off
what it's mental because it was probably
about here and then it just suddenly
went like bang yes
it's sort of like necked in where it
broke because there that was where it
was most stretched and even in slow-mo
it was instant absolute yes if we
probably need a million frames to get
the the propagation of that crack the
machines just made me feel completely
inadequate well yeah I mean I can pull
one ten back hopefully you enjoyed that
video feel free to follow us on Twitter
subscribe we've got loads of slow-mo we
got a second channel we've got merch and
unless no if you like these science
related videos I do I bloody do you buy
do you love science no you don't love it